hello everyone I don't have any pumpkins
or costumes to do this video with but a
subscriber reminded me that it's
Halloween and that I could do a nice
Halloween gambit game and as I do enjoy
an occasional Halloween gambit myself I
decided this was worth a video the game
was played in 1994 it was the Bulgaria
team championship and it was played
between a Grigor mint chip and alexander
petrov I couldn't find the photo of any
of these guys so Alexander Petrov gets
the usual hooli photo the hoodie guy and
well in this case a Greek or miniature
who decided to go for the Halloween
gambit gets the hoodie guy Halloween
edition photo so let's see this game we
have E 4 E 592 f3 Knight to f6 Knight to
c3 and Knight to c6 this is the four
Knights game and in this position white
has a lot of options available to him
for example Bishop to b5 Bishop to c4
even Bishop to e2 was played d3 was play
d4 was played even a3 or h3 a lot of
options here but there is a one option
that is called the Halloween gambit and
that is Knight captures on e5 and what
does this do well of course you do give
up your knight Knight captures on e5 and
now d4 you give up a piece but now
you're gonna get some great expansion in
the center and mr. Petrov replies with
Knight to c6 a little better defense
would be Knight to g6 but okay he played
knight Knight to c6 and we have d5 and
well here he decided to play Knight back
to e5 but in this position black can
actually equalize pretty pretty easily
there is this move Bishop to b4
available to him giving back the
material but staying with a better
position for example D captures on c6
and now Knight captures on e4 the c3
Knight is pinned Queen to d4
we have Queen to e7 now threatening
discoveries with the Knight Bishop to e3
and after Knight captures on c3 and a3
Bishop to d6 now C captures and d7 with
Czech Bishop captures and Queen captures
on c3
Bishop to c6 and the material is equal
but the black already has two developed
pieces white only has this dark square
bishop to both sides already to castle
and this beautiful light square bishop
on c6 is preventing this light square
bishop from developing as the g2 point
would be hanging so a pretty equal
position but slightly in favor of black
so this is also possible but after d5 he
played Knight to e5 and now we had f4
getting further expansion now Knight to
g6 and now II five and I gather again
here a Bishop to b4 move is also
possible and but okay Knight the g8 was
played and the black is still better
here he he's up a piece and he should
definitely try to undermine this
beautiful pawn chain White has in the
center we have d6 and this is a move a
bit too over over-optimistic for white
we have a C capture son b6 e capture son
b6 and now white is definitely
threatening a move like Queen to e2
check
black will have to block this check and
the white will regain the piece back so
we have Queen to f6
black is making room for the King Gandhi
eight Knights the b5 now defending the
d6 pawn has the bishop and the Queen
were attacking it and threatening night
to c7 check and here black plays rook to
b8 black black wants to preserve too
much material and this will be his
downfall a much more resilient move
would be something like Knight captures
on f4 and after Knight to c7 and King to
b8 for example if you capture the rook
Knight captures rook an a8 we have Queen
to e5 check and now black is definitely
the one on the attack
for example Bishop to e2 and now you
have Knight characters and g2 this is
buck is much better here but instead
after Knight to be five black decided to
get a bit too materialistic which there
really is no reason for I mean why did
give up a piece for the attack you do
have to give something back so we have
rook to b8 and the Bishop to e3 now the
developing and also kind of attacking
this a7 pawn but I don't really believe
this is worth defending but black
defends this
well we have b6 and now we have Queen to
eat too now threatening discoveries with
the bishop came back to the ate as he
does have to get away from that Queen's
x-ray white does the queenside castle
and here white is still down a piece but
if you look at the position his pieces
are placed tremendously and the sparking
is stuck on d8 this pawn on d6 is
completely blocking black from
developing either way we have Queen to
e6 and now a beautiful a beautiful move
that deflects the black Queen Queens
defense of the C 4 square we have f f5
and here if black doesn't want to lose a
piece he does have to capture the pawn
so we have Queen Katherine f5 and Queen
to c4 now with the ideas of Quintus c7
check and probably a move like rook to
be 7 or kink the e8 would would favor
black here but white is simply the white
has too much here Queen to e5 was played
and we have Queen to c7 check in to e8
and now Bishop to d4 what a temple on
the Queen but also freeing this key file
for the rook so the rook can come to the
file with tempo Queen to f4 now getting
the Queen out of the way with check King
to b1 and rook to e8 black still wants
to save this rook as if as if this this
is gonna help him anyhow rook the rook
to e1 check and here black is sadly out
of options he does have to give back the
piece Bishop to e7 was played we have g3
and now comes Queen to d2 if you play a
move like Queen to a5 you get D captures
on e7
and this is terrible for black there is
no defense against Knight to d6
so after g3 Queen to d2 was tried
attacking the rook and e2 so now if D
captures on e7 black would capture of
course the rook with checkmate but why
it solves this problem quite easily with
Bishop to g2 and now connecting the
rooks the bishop is not also attacking
this rook of course white isn't
interested in the rook at all but
black has no squink a person g2 was
played and now D captures on e7 and
white simply has too many threats black
cannot stop them all
for example Queen to d8 with checkmate
is a threat if you try and stop this for
example with Bishop to b7 you get Knight
to d6 this is checkmate as the pawn is
protected from the rook on e1 so after D
captures an e7 black tried night 8
captures on e7 we have Knight to d6 with
check King to f8 and Queen to d8
checkmate so yeah a beautiful game
bye-bye mr. goody-good min chef who
sadly I couldn't find a photo of him and
it's interesting this was a classical
game so I don't know I know I mean I
used the Halloween bit a couple of times
in my own games probably you do as well
but I'm interested if any of you have
used the Halloween gambit in a classical
tournament you know with classical tank
controls so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank David Felix Blake gorg an unknown
person and non Shiblon for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it for those of
you who enjoy such things have a happy
Halloween and have a good time as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon